[stadium crowd noise]
(A.C. Slater)
All right!
(Team)
[cheering]
(A.C. Slater)
This is it, guys!
(Aisha)
And girl.
(A.C. Slater)
Right, I wouldn’t want to forget about
our star quarterback-ette.
(A.C. Slater)
Our...  quarterbacktress!
Quarterwoman?
(Aisha)
Just quarterback.
(A.C. Slater)
It is Bayside versus Valley,
it is the biggest game in the country!
(Jamie)
Oooff, Coach,
what about the match up on NBC?
(Jamie)
That is objectively a way bigger game than this.
(A.C. Slater)
Well, debatable.
We need to work together as a group.
(Aisha)
Hey Coach!
Back to the football comparison,
(Aisha)
record breaking plays,
Hall of Fame seasons and...
(Aisha)
they’re professional athletes.
(Jamie)
Yeah, and we’re just  a  high school team
that hasn’t won a game in like
(Jamie)
twenty-seven years.
(A.C. Slater)
Okay, but...
let’s focus on this game, because...
(Aisha)
Hey, did you guys catch
last week’s game, because
(Aisha)
my Fantasy Football running back
got thirty-eight points.
(Aisha)
How’d that L taste, Jamie?
(Team)
Ohhhhh!
(Jamie)
Please stop reminding me.
It’s not my fault that I forgot to start a defense.
(Aisha)
Uh, actually it is.
(A.C. Slater)
Guys, guys!
Ehh and girl!
(A.C. Slater)
My point is...
this is a big game.
(A.C. Slater)
This is our time.
It is Bayside versus Valley.
(A.C. Slater)
This game is huge.
Everyone is gonna be watching.
(Jamie)
My parents aren’t here,
they’re at home
(Jamie)
watching the football game on NBC.
(Aisha)
Speaking of watching,
are they going to be showing the game on the sidelines?
(A.C. Slater)
I give up.
I’m going to the Max to have some soup.
[clap]